Musique grave
-27 juin 2023.
...
La mort à Nanterre du jeune Nahel
lors d'un contrôle de police
provoque dans toute la France
un embrasement
d'une ampleur inédite.
Pendant six nuits,
des épisodes de violences urbaines
se succèdent
dans les grandes métropoles,
mais aussi dans des villes
qui n'avaient jamais affronté
de telles situations.
Ils sont policiers, commerçants,
élus, mères de famille,
habitants des quartiers, magistrats.
Ils vivent à Vaulx-en-Velin,
en banlieue de Lyon,
et à Montargis, dans le Loiret.
Trois mois après les émeutes
dans ces deux villes,
nous avons
rencontré celles et ceux
qui étaient hier en première ligne
et qui dessinent
aujourd'hui la vie d'après.
Musique douce
Elle est surnommée
avec un peu d'emphase
la Venise du Gâtinais.
Montargis,
sous-préfecture du Loiret,
a la réputation
d'une cité tranquille.
A 1h30 de Paris,
une ville-étape
appréciée pour son centre historique
et ses canaux.
Mais depuis quelques semaines,
une plaie béante défigure
la carte postale.
Derrière ces barrières,
au mois de juin encore,
se trouvaient
la pharmacie du centre,
une chocolaterie et une cordonnerie.
Mais au cours d'une nuit d'émeutes,
ces commerces sont tous
partis en fumée,
incendiés volontairement.
-Plus rien.
Tout est anéanti,
tout est détruit.
12 ans de...
De travail,
et voilà, quoi, plus rien.
-Patrick Vriet était le patron
de la chocolaterie.
Jamais il n'aurait imaginé
de telles scènes possibles
dans la ville.
-C'était la façade, carrément,
qui s'est écroulée.
On se serait cru en temps de guerre.
C'était impressionnant.
On n'en croyait pas nos yeux.
C'est une petite
ville tranquille.
On n'est pas
dans les grosses villes,
les grosses villes comme Marseille,
ou Bordeaux.
On se demande ce qui nous tombe
sur la tête, quoi.
C'est juste pas possible.
-La nuit de l'incendie,
le centre commerçant
de la petite ville
tranquille est mise à sac
par près de 250 émeutiers cagoulés.
Du jamais vu à Montargis.
Pour les habitants,
un traumatisme...
*-C'est une dinguerie,
ce qui se passe.
-...durable.
-Je n'ai jamais vu
une émeute comme ça
nulle part de ma vie.
Pourtant, j'ai connu Mai 68.
Mais...
Voir ça...
-Ouais, c'est...
C'est de la folie, hein.
-C'était de la folie.
Il m'a fallu une semaine
pour retrouver le calme
et un peu de...
-Cette rue, maintenant,
elle est triste.
Vous regardez à droite, à gauche,
tout est fermé, c'est calfeutré.
-C'est ça.
-Enfin, c'est une catastrophe.
-Trois mois plus tard,
la rue Dorée,
poumon commerçant de Montargis,
reste couverte de cicatrices.
Les sorties shopping du samedi
n'y ont plus
la même saveur.
Les impacts sur les vitrines,
les palissades en bois
rappellent encore en permanence
la violence de cette nuit-là.
Patrick Vriet ne sait pas
s'il rouvrira un jour
sa boutique.
En attendant, il est soutenu
par les commerçants voisins.
Les émeutes
sont encore dans les têtes.
-Pour l'instant,
c'est pas possible
de tourner la page,
après trois mois, non,
c'est... impossible.
Mais on est dedans tous les jours.
Tout me rappelle,
tous les papiers,
les fournisseurs.
Je suis dedans tous les jours.
-Avant, je ne fermais pas
mes rideaux métalliques.
Il y a le système d'alarme.
Enfin voilà, on se dit
qu'il n'arrivera rien,
et pourtant, maintenant,
tous les soirs,
j'ai pris le pli
et l'habitude
de fermer mes rideaux métalliques,
parce que peut-être,
on sait pas, ça peut recommencer,
parce que peut-être
qu'un policier va faire
quelque chose,
malheureusement, accidentellement,
que ça va encore partir
un peu de là...
-Que ça va encore dégénérer.
-Bon courage pour la suite.
-Je vous tiens au courant.
-Avec plaisir,
c'est gentil.
-Merci, à bientôt.
Au revoir.
-80 commerces
ont été attaqués à Montargis.
Sébastien Drapala est le chef
de la police municipale.
Il était positionné
dans la rue Dorée
le soir des émeutes.
-Cette boutique-là,
c'est une boutique téléphonique
qui avait été également pillée
de tout son contenu.
Depuis, ça a pas rouvert.
Le magasin est resté
en stand-by, comme ça.
C'était rapide,
avec de la mobilité,
des téléphones
à mettre dans les poches.
Après, ils ont essayé
des bijouteries.
Les bijouteries ont
des vitres plus sécurisées,
donc ils ont pas pu entrer.
-Face aux émeutiers,
les policiers ont tenté
vaille que vaille
de défendre la rue commerçante,
mais sans parvenir
à éviter le saccage.
-On était une quinzaine
contre 100 à 150 individus.
Dès qu'on essayait de progresser
pour repousser les individus,
malheureusement,
pour notre sécurité,
on devait reculer.
Coups de feu
On essuyait trop de tirs de mortier,
de mobilier urbain,
donc on a à chaque fois reculé.
On a essayé...
La police nationale a utilisé
des grenades lacrymogènes,
les lanceurs
de balles de défense,
mais on n'a pas pu les repousser
vu le nombre d'individus.
Les véhicules qui étaient
encore stationnés,
ils les retournaient
pour les incendier,
pour faire des barrages.
Ce qui est resté,
les panneaux publicitaires,
tout a été incendié ou jeté
vers les forces de l'ordre.
Des affrontements
et avec autant
de personnes structurées,
avec une haine de telle ampleur,
je n'ai jamais
connu ça sur Montargis.
-Pendant que les policiers
faisaient front,
à quelques rues de là,
le maire, lui, passait la nuit
au centre de vidéosurveillance
de la ville.
-Monsieur le maire.
-Ca va bien ?
-Bien et vous ?
-Oui.
J'étais là, avec monsieur
le sous-préfet de Montargis,
un des adjoints
et mon chef de cabinet.
On a assisté au désastre,
au pillage de la ville.
Quand vous êtes comme ça,
vous êtes collé devant les écrans.
Vous voyez des images.
C'est quasiment irréel.
On ne se rend pas compte
de ce qui se passe.
On s'en rend compte,
mais le temps que vous absorbiez
ce choc...
Il faut du temps.
On ne peut pas être prêt
face à un tsunami.
Personne n'est prêt
face à ça.
Un tsunami ou un blitzkrieg,
comme vous voulez,
mais c'est une guerre-éclair,
une vague qui est passée
en 3 heures.
On ne peut pas supposer
que ça existe.
Maintenant, on le sait.
C'est quelque chose
de terrible.
C'est soudain,
ce n'est pas attendu.
On sait qu'il y a des difficultés.
Les difficultés économiques,
on les connaît,
mais c'est pas lié à tout ça.
C'est lié à une vague,
à un défouloir.
Je vous ai dit,
c'est le défouloir
d'une jeunesse qui s'est lâchée
mais emmenée par des leaders
qui sont des gens négatifs.
-Effectivement,
on voit que c'est quand même
structuré et organisé,
donc je pense qu'il y a eu
des rassemblements
via les réseaux sociaux.
Ils sont arrivés à 150-200 personnes
en même temps, au même endroit,
en centre-ville.
On voit qu'il y a eu
une organisation.
Ca a été structuré en amont,
effectivement, oui.
-Les images de vidéosurveillance
ont été transmises au parquet.
Certains émeutiers,
interpellés en flagrant délit,
ont été jugés en comparution
immédiate juste après les faits.
Ces audiences ont permis
de mieux cerner leurs profils,
leur organisation
et leurs motivations.
Jean-Cédric Gaux est
le procureur de Montargis.
Il a vu les prévenus
se succéder à la barre.
-Les forces de l'ordre
ont interpellé
et nous avons pris des décisions
pour 18 individus,
18 émeutiers.
Il y a, parmi ces 18 personnes,
10 mineurs et 8 majeurs,
Donc, l'immense majorité
de ces individus,
ils n'avaient pas
d'antécédents judiciaires.
Presque la quasi-totalité
étaient simplement connus, parfois,
des services de police
qui les côtoient dans les quartiers
de Montargis
et de son agglomération.
A aucun moment il y a eu
d'évocation de Nahel M
à l'origine de ces émeutes.
A aucun moment il n'y a eu,
par exemple,
de tags revendicatifs.
A aucun moment, aucune revendication
de nature politique,
on pourrait dire,
n'a été faite.
Il a été évoqué une présence
opportuniste
ou un effet de groupe,
peut-être du suivisme.
-Pas de message évident
derrière ces actes,
qui disent tout de même
quelque chose sur Montargis.
-Ce qui m'est apparu de nouveau,
c'est la révélation, peut-être,
du fossé qui s'élargissait entre,
eh bien,
une partie de notre jeunesse qui vit
dans les quartiers difficiles...
Vous observerez que le fait,
pour ces quartiers
dits périphériques à la ville,
de venir dans le centre-ville,
dans la principale rue commerçante,
c'était un acte symbolique,
me semble-t-il,
de l'appréhension que j'en ai,
de vengeance pour dire
au centre-ville "riche"
qu'il y avait
des difficultés sociales
dans les quartiers de périphérie.
-La Chaussée est l'un des quartiers
périphériques de Montargis.
En bas des tours,
nous rencontrons des mères
de famille isolées prises en charge
par une association.
Alors que les habitants
du centre-ville restent sidérés,
leur ressenti à elles
n'est pas le même.
-Moi, perso,
ça ne m'a pas surprise.
Tous les soirs,
on entend des tirs de mortiers,
lundi, mardi, mercredi,
des crosses toutes les nuits.
Même à 9h le matin...
-On a des voitures
brûlées régulièrement.
-Ma voiture, ma voiture.
Je me suis fait voler ma voiture
Elle a brûlé dans les champs,
plus loin.
-Je pense aussi que les jeunes,
quand ils voient
leurs parents, aussi,
galérer alors qu'il y en a
qui ont tout,
ça peut faire...
Ca peut énerver,
ça peut, voilà.
-Ca peut conduire à aller
péter deux-trois vitrines
la nuit pour prendre, revendre.
-Quand vous voyez que le copain
à l'école, il a eu un scooter
et que vous arrivez pas à avoir
un vélo pour venir à l'école...
J'excuse pas, mais je dis
qu'à un moment,
quand on est enfant, même ado,
on se dit c'est pas juste.
-J'ai un enfant de 14 ans difficile
et j'ai eu peur.
Je les ai surveillés
et maintenus à la maison.
Il ne faut pas lâcher la garde,
il faut être vigilant.
Il y a quand même
une violence qui augmente.
-60 % des mineurs interpellés
lors des émeutes
sont issus
de familles monoparentales.
Dans ces quartiers,
difficile, parfois,
pour les mères seules de maintenir
leurs enfants loin des violences.
-Ils sont curieux,
le danger ne leur fait pas peur.
Ils sont pas conscients et vont
peut-être le faire en groupe.
C'est de ça qu'on a peur,
quand ils sont en bande
et s'entraînent à faire des choses,
-Je pense pas que nous, parents,
on ait la mainmise sur tout.
Je dis tout ce qui est bien
à ma fille,
mais je suis pas à l'abri
qu'un jour,
elle décide de faire l'inverse
car elle aura envie d'essayer.
-C'est difficile aux mamans
d'être au travail le matin,
de surveiller les enfants,
de rentrer tard le soir
les enfants, s'ils ne sont pas là,
d'aller les chercher.
Je pense
que la responsabilité familiale,
certes, ça peut exister,
mais ce n'est pas une généralité.
-Entre les mises en garde
des parents,
la tentation d'aller voir
ce qui se passe
et les vidéos circulant
sur leurs écrans,
les adolescents des quartiers
de Montargis ont été bouleversés
par la spirale des événements.
-Je le voyais sur les réseaux.
Sur Snapchat
et sur Instagram, partout,
et c'est même passé sur BFM TV.
-Dans certaines villes,
c'était en mode :
qui cassera le plus ?
-Ce n'est même plus par rapport
à la mort de Nahel.
Carrément, je suis sortie
avec ma mère
et j'ai entendu des gens
qui disaient :
"Rassemblez les mortiers."
Ils allaient faire ça le soir même.
Je les entendais parler de ça.
Comme par hasard, après,
on a vu sur les réseaux,
je vais pas balancer où,
mais la cachette.
-C'est quoi, ces stéréotypes ?
-"Les jeunes des quartiers,
"ils sont tous comme ça
à cause de certaines personnes."
Ils font une généralité
avec tous les jeunes
des quartiers qui sont comme ça.
-Encore sonnée,
la ville tente, pas à pas,
de retrouver sa vie d'avant.
Musique douce
Aujourd'hui,
le maire rend visite
au gérant d'un bar-tabac qui vient
de recevoir une bonne nouvelle.
-Bonjour. Ca va ?
-Ca va et vous ?
-Ca y est ?
-Oui, impeccable.
-On a eu l'arrêté, hier soir,
de l'expert,
mais il y a aucun problème,
vous pouvez rouvrir.
Vous aurez
la communication lundi,
mais là, il est arrivé à 21h
hier soir
et on a on a l'expert
judiciaire à valider.
-Merci beaucoup à vous.
-Ca a repris ?
La livraison de tabac
est arrivée ?
-Pour vous, voir un commerce
qui rouvre ?
-C'est une victoire.
Je suis content pour lui.
Ca fait trois mois
qu'il tire la langue,
qu'il n'a plus de revenus.
-Le quotidien du maire
reste accaparé
par les suites de la nuit d'émeutes.
-J'y passe
5-6 heures par jour.
Les gens se rendent pas compte
du travail pour la mairie.
Les services sont sous tension.
C'est les assurances,
les experts, les avocats,
les assurés, aussi,
les gens de la ville,
faire en sorte que les vitrines
soient remises
en service normalement.
Travaillez bien
et remplissez la caisse.
-Bonne journée !
-Aider les commerces à rouvrir,
C'est la priorité de Benoît Digeon.
Mais il a une autre obsession.
-Remettre du bleu
dans la ville, voilà,
de l'autorité, des policiers.
Il nous manque une trentaine
d'effectifs à la police nationale.
Il faut que ces effectifs
soient retrouvés.
M. Darmanin n'y coupera pas.
Même s'il nous annonce
10 policiers au mois de novembre,
il y en a 10 qui s'en vont,
donc pour nous,
l'opération est blanche.
-Des moyens de police
en réponse
à une réalité nouvelle :
les flambées de violence
peuvent désormais frapper
tout le territoire français.
Comme Montargis,
de très nombreuses villes
petites et moyennes
ont été touchées par les émeutes.
De façon plus attendue,
les zones périphériques
des grandes métropoles
se sont aussi enflammées.
Dans l'agglomération lyonnaise,
il est une ville dont l'image
est depuis longtemps associée
aux affrontements urbains :
Vaulx-en-Velin.
Tout le contraire de Montargis,
ici, cette réalité est ancrée
depuis plusieurs générations.
C'est à Vaulx-en-Velin
que la France a connu
sa première grande série
d'émeutes en 1990.
-La nuit dernière,
des jeunes se sont affrontés
avec des policiers.
Tout a démarré
après la mort d'un jeune motard.
-Le pilote d'une Honda
1000 cm3 perd le contrôle
de sa moto.
En sens inverse,
arrive une voiture de police.
Le passager de la moto sans casque,
Thomas Claudio, 21 ans,
est décédé durant son transfert
à l'hôpital.
-21h30, hier soir,
les jeunes se rassemblent.
Rodéos, jets de pierres,
ils brûlent
leur première voiture.
-Ces combats continuent.
Une odeur de gaz lacrymogène
plane sur la ville.
Elle entame sa 3e nuit chaude.
-J'ai peur, j'ai des enfants.
Je voudrais pas que ça recommence.
J'ai jamais vu ça.
-Jaafar Greinch
est un militant associatif
très impliqué dans le quartier
sensible du Mas du Taureau.
C'est là qu'avaient débuté
les émeutes de 1990.
-J'avais cinq ans,
donc je n'ai pas trop de souvenirs.
Les seuls souvenirs que je garde
de ces événements-là, en 90,
c'est un soir,
on rentrait avec mon père,
et en rentrant,
je vois la place du Mas du Taureau,
qui est un peu plus haut,
qui est complètement barricadée
ou remplie de cars de CRS.
-33 ans plus tard,
Vaulx-en-Velin s'est
à nouveau embrasé.
Cris et détonation
Ici, presque pas de pillages,
comme à Montargis,
mais des scènes de violence
proches de la guérilla urbaine
avec la police.
La question des relations
avec les forces de l'ordre semble
ici beaucoup plus prégnante.
-Comment ça va ?
-Jaafar Greinch chez les membres
de son association dialoguent
au quotidien avec les jeunes
du Mas du Taureau.
Ils essaient de comprendre
les mécanismes
à l'origine des tensions
avec la police.
-Si on vous pose la question,
aujourd'hui,
vous avez vécu comment
les derniers événements ?
Tu trouves normal que ça ait pété
à Vaulx ?
-C'est normal.
Moi, je trouve ça normal.
Je trouve ça normal
parce que c'est inadmissible,
ce qui s'est passé à Paris.
C'est quelque chose
de hors du commun.
-Le fait que Nahel...
-Le fait que le policier
ait tiré sur Nahel à bout portant
de plusieurs balles.
-Ca aurait pu arriver
à tout le monde.
-Je me suis dit : il a 17 ans,
ça aurait pu être nous,
ça aurait pu être moi,
lui, lui.
Ca aurait pu être
n'importe qui qui est d'ici.
-J'étais pour les émeutes
parce que,
entre la police
qui nous fait des bavures
à chaque fois qu'ils nous voient,
qui nous insultent,
qui se moquent de nous,
entre ça et entre la mort de Nahel,
moi, j'ai trouvé
qu'ils le méritaient.
-On a souvent parlé de ça.
Quand il dit "pour",
c'est entre parenthèses.
C'est compréhensible
que ça peut être mérité,
que certaines personnes pensent
que c'est que c'est mérité
de se révolter.
Comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure,
on pense tous pareil
du fait que,
du moment où ils ont
le même uniforme
et ils ont les mêmes services,
les mêmes pratiques,
ils sont tous dans le même lot.
-Peut-être qu'il vous voit
aussi comme étant tous
dans le même sac.
-J'ai pas d'uniforme.
-La relation avec l'institution
n'est pas stable,
il faut la recréer.
-L'institution ?
-Ca peut être l'institution-Etat,
l'institution-police,
l'institution-ville.
Tout ça, en fait.
-Police, il faudrait renouer.
Après, il s'est passé
trop de trucs.
-Ca va être compliqué.
-Ca va être compliqué
des deux côtés, du coup.
-Oui, des deux côtés,
c'est sûr.
*Signal radio
-Côté forces de l'ordre,
les émeutes de juin
ont aussi laissé des traces
et accentué un malaise.
*...
Nous sommes avec la compagnie
départementale d'intervention
de la police nationale,
16 hommes qui ont
affronté les émeutiers
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise.
Pour nous en parler,
ils nous emmènent
sur le plateau des Minguettes,
commune de Vénissieux.
-C'est une zone un petit
peu sensible, forcément, où,
pour travailler, il y a
certaines précautions à prendre.
D'une manière générale,
quand on arrive ce soir-là,
le tram est bloqué juste
en face de nous par les émeutiers
et on est accueillis
avec un jet de projectiles.
On s'est aperçu qu'ils étaient
de plus en plus nombreux,
qu'ils cherchaient à créer
une espèce de "front"
face à nous et ils tentaient
de nous contourner.
Ca a été pendant presque 1h30,
quasiment 2 heures,
beaucoup de moyens
pyrotechniques, quasiment,
pas non-stop mais pas loin.
Enormément de feux d'artifices,
de mortiers.
-Est-ce que vous ressentez
de la haine
à votre encontre
chez les émeutiers ?
-Oui, clairement.
L'objectif est de casser du flic,
pour certains, on le sait.
Sur ce genre d'événements,
enfin, on entend
énormément d'insultes,
de menaces de mort et autres.
Après, voilà, le dialogue est
quand même assez restreint.
Une fois que la situation
est dégradée à ce point-là,
il y a quand même
assez peu de dialogue.
-Un constat s'impose :
c'est aujourd'hui l'impasse
entre les policiers et certains
habitants des quartiers.
-Il y a le terrain qui a été
on va dire, au niveau des banlieues,
qui a été un peu perdu,
mais pour plein de raisons,
pas forcément en lien
avec les interventions
des forces de l'ordre.
On n'arrive plus à discuter.
c'est difficile.
La mentalité des jeunes a changé,
donc c'est pas forcément évident.
Avant, il y avait des...
Si on peut parler
au niveau social,
il y avait des éducateurs
qui faisaient aussi le lien
entre la police et la population,
dans les cités.
Nous aussi, on avait
des services spécifiques d'îlotage
qui allaient au contact.
Petit à petit,
on n'a plus eu ces services.
Peut-être qu'au niveau social,
il y a eu
moins d'éducateurs,
ce qui a fait que l'écart,
le fossé s'est creusé petit à petit
entre la population,
une partie de la population,
et les policiers.
Comment installer un dialogue
durable et constructif
entre la police
et les habitants des cités ?
A Vaulx-en-Velin, Jaafar Greinch
et Abdallah Slimani travaillent
sur cette question
depuis des années.
Ils avaient lancé en 2019
un projet baptisé PoliCité,
qui proposait
des moments de rencontre.
-Je me souviens
de la première rencontre
qu'il y avait eu,
c'était magique.
Tu voyais des jeunes
avec des policiers,
tout le monde
autour de la table,
et des gens qui disaient :
"On voyait pas le truc comme ça.
"On voyait pas votre métier
comme ça."
-Au début, on a eu des accès
qui nous ont été facilités
par la préfecture
pour aller discuter
avec les commissariats,
avec les collèges où, là,
on avait une marge de manoeuvre
pour vraiment mettre
en place des actions.
Après, du jour au lendemain,
ça a été beaucoup plus difficile.
La fonction publique,
c'est ça.
On peut avoir un préfet
avec qui on peut discuter
pendant 2-3 ans,
et après, on aura
un nouveau préfet qui, lui,
est moins
sur cette ligne de dialogue
entre les forces de l'ordre
et les jeunes,
ou même les habitants,
plus largement.
-Pour penser la relation
avec la police,
une autre piste est évoquée :
une Convention citoyenne
sur la sécurité,
sur le modèle de celles
déjà lancées par l'Elysée
sur l'environnement
et la fin de vie.
-Ouvrir un débat national
sur la sécurité pour dire
qu'il y a un problème.
Dedans, il y a la formation,
les pratiques policières,
les moyens policiers,
la place, justement,
des habitants
dans cette construction
des politiques,
la place des syndicats aussi.
-Vaulx-en-Velin est
depuis des années
un laboratoire
des réflexions politiques
sur les quartiers populaires.
C'est en réaction aux émeutes
du Mas du Taureau de 1990
que la France s'était dotée
d'un ministère de la Ville.
La socialiste Hélène Geoffroy
y a occupé le poste de secrétaire
d'Etat sous le mandat
de François Hollande.
Elle est maire de Vaulx-en-Velin
et fait une proposition :
la création d'un parquet
anti-émeute.
-De même qu'on a des parquets
spécialisés sur les questions
financières
ou les questions liées
aux attentats,
pour recréer un lien de confiance.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Lorsque vous interrogez
les plus jeunes, ils disent :
"La police, quoi qu'elle fasse,
elle a une forme d'impunité.
"Elle peut faire ce qu'elle veut,
on ne saura jamais la vérité."
De l'autre côté,
des policiers qui disent :
"On défend quand il y a des émeutes,
on est parfois en danger
"et il n'y a pas de reconnaissance
de la nation."
Au milieu, une IGPN
qui ne peut pas
remplir tous les rôles :
c'est le contrôle de la police.
Il faut la tierce personne
entre les jeunes et la police.
C'est l'autorité judiciaire
qui peut avoir ce regard.
-Augmenter les effectifs de police,
créer un nouveau cadre juridique,
faire se rencontrer
policiers et population,
à Montargis et Vaulx-en-Velin,
des idées et des propositions
sont sur la table.
L'enjeu : empêcher que, demain,
une nouvelle étincelle
ne provoque encore
un embrasement général.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA